watching this movie I'm just gonna claim
that there's gonna be a third I'm just
gonna say it if Jack's in it I'm in it
so I was gonna ask you
to get in it
of course I love this Shack anytime he's
near me I'm happier who's on who's on
list to get in the third one any I mean
I don't know I I love being I like me
and Anderson have a great time and
whoever wants to get murdered hang out
for six seven weeks eight weeks
somewhere it's it's a good time
Paris Hawaii I mean damn can't be the
next next one is wherever Shaq says
well the big um the big murder goes down
at the big party right so and Jennifer
is hanging out near the buffet so in
real life where does Adam Sandler hang
out at the park I struggle to stay away
from the buffet I got away I look at it
I start going ah let me have one french
fry then once it starts it's over but
I'll go to like 10 30 without hitting
the buffet and then it's over I'm like
you in the movie I go straight for the
block of cheese
she's just fun come on
come on I bought a little more than that
apart when I'm out of party and people
are talking like you guys got that
cheese man I'll go with my own that's
something about it you just said that
you were kind of fibby saying that you
were up to play Ross and friends you
said an interview I guess that Schwimmer
was nicer and taller I thought well he
he is but
but I did I know that wasn't real I was
just joking we did come up with a little
bit of an idea the other day about what
a trio movie could be oh three yes
[Applause]
incredible I love what you talked you
guys talked about on Drew Barrymore when
you said you'd explore the idea of doing
a Three's Company remake people are
losing their minds about this Adam what
do we have to do to really get that
going I mean honestly I don't know if
that's the one that would be funny I'm
sure if someone wrote a great script but
uh Jack Tripper is the best by the way I
don't think I'm Jack Tripper I could see
so many Comics too I I said that he's a
stud of a guy and I was just he is
warmer I
because my hair wasn't perfect
just in case
he's repping the Knicks I see
you
Melanie likes it
everybody likes it
folks here would like it more if it was
a Lakers emblem on the front but you
know what I'm your French site
by the end of the shoot Melanie would
see me and be like why is he wearing
that man you and your wife were
celebrating a big milestone this year 20
years married 20th wedding anniversary
it's funny we've been together for 25 so
we like always act like that's our
anniversary tonight we met but 20 is
good 20 years of marriage that's nice
can I just say if I may when you guys
came down the carpet I was admiring I'm
like she has legs for days yeah she got
better legs than me I'll give her that
there you go I think I have uh you know
a better profile
yeah yeah no she's winning on the on a
lot
thank you so much Adam
[Music]